you have these two lists side by side
you've got all the fears and doubts and
then you've got the opposite essentially
affirmations of the new beliefs I always
say when you look at these two lists
side by side if you looked at them as
two different people
person a and person B what kind of
career would person a have this list of
fears and doubts that's their belief
system what kind of career do you think
they're going to have and it's usually
well they probably won't get very far
they're probably going to struggle and
then what about person B these
affirmations this new belief system what
kind of career do you think they're
going to have you know it's usually
they're gonna kick butt they're gonna do
great and the whole point of this is not
to say you can never have these fears
again you know I think the doubts and
the fears they're always going to be
there they might change over time the
point is we want the second list to be
in the driver's seat
so the fears and doubts it's okay to
have them they're still going to hang
out in the back seat of the car but we
want the affirmations the new list the
new beliefs driving the show